[Music]
washington journal continues
joining us now jefferson morley he's the
author of cia and jfk the secret
assassination files he is also the
author of the ghost of the secret life
of cia spy master james jesus angleton
uh mr morley thanks for joining us
thanks for having me pedro could you
talk about your work as someone who
researches the events of jfk's murder
my background is writing books about the
cia and i've written three biographies
of major
officials in the cia in the 1960s
when scott was the chief of the mexico
city station in the 1960s my book our
man in mexico is a biography of him
james angleton was the chief of counter
intelligence at the cia from 1954 to
1974 and my book the ghost is a
biography of him and i have a
forthcoming book scorpions dance which
is the story of richard nixon and
richard helms the eighth director of the
cia so wynn scott jim angleton and
richard helms were all
major cia officials from the 1950s to
the 1970s they were all friends they
were all intimately involved in the
events of 1963. so i don't write about
the kennedy assassination per se i write
about the kennedy assassination in the
context of the cia what's important to
understand for our viewers to understand
your perspective then of that of that
position that you take because i i don't
write about conspiracy theories i write
about what the events of november 1963
looked like to cia insiders
this is the story that we now know not a
story that could be known in 1963 but
how did these men see what happened in
dallas what happened to the president
what happened with the investigation and
how did they respond and what we see in
all three stories is the idea that one
man alone came along and killed the
president for no reason
none of these men acted like that was
the case rather they acted like lee
harvey oswald was a very sensitive
matter who's who's
whose knowledge whose actions and whose
knowledge by the cia had to be held very
closely and what we saw this week is a
process that is still unfolding the cia
is still holding very closely certain
information about kennedy's
assassination so my book is does my
books are designed to open up this and
say what did the kennedy assassination
look like to the cia itself when it
comes then to that information that you
talk about there was a release of
documents recently by the national
archives talk about that release and
also put it into perspective what's
totally held by the archives concerning
the jfk assassination okay so last week
um
1409
documents that contained redactions
omitted material
uh were released in full for the first
time
14 000 documents related to kennedy's
assassination remain continue to have
redactions in them so we only got less
than 10 percent of the outstanding
documents last week
also it's important to understand when
you when you think about that release
why are we releasing records well in
1992 congress passed a law the jfk
records act
at that point oliver stone had just made
his movie and had scored points in
public opinion by by pointing out the
very true fact that 30 years after the
assassination
almost all of the government's records
on the subject were classified
information
stone put a little trailer at the end of
his movie and he said you know if you
object to this write your congressman
capitol hill was inundated with mail
saying why don't why doesn't the
government release its information and
congress was shamed into doing the right
thing and they passed a pretty good law
the jfk records act said we are going to
release all jfk records we're gonna
we're gonna clear the
the record we're gonna make this
transparent to everybody we want all jfk
records to be public and they created a
process to do that
they created something called the
assassination records review board this
was an independent board made up of
civilian experts and they went to each
government agency and said show us your
jfk records
we will review them for classified
information and then we will make them
public and in the 1990s that's what they
did and they declassified
more than 300 000 records related to
kennedy's assassination 5 million pages
so this was a big step forward in terms
of
completing the historical record of
kennedy's assassination uh oh well go
ahead i'm sorry yeah so so um but
the law gave the agencies primarily the
cia and fbi but government agencies the
right to withhold certain
information for us for a certain amount
of time but what congress said was after
25 years everything has to be made
public so the law was passed in 1992 25
years later october 2017
the question came to president trump and
the cia director mike pompeo went to
trump and said we cannot release this
information we have to keep it secret
now if i may interrupt i apologize
some of those concerns cited because of
national security what do you think
about that as an argument
i mean if you look at the records and
you see what is withheld on national
security grounds you will laugh
it will be things like
we had an intelligence relationship with
the british british government that was
one of the things that was that was
released this week in a document we had
a intelligence relations and it was
blanked out and when they took it off it
said british now is it a national
security secret that the u.s has
intelligence relations with britain
that's preposterous but that's the kind
of thing that's going on is wild over
classification
national security is is given as the
justification
but when you look at what is actually
withheld it's very very rarely
something that is rises to the level of
of national security um in these
documents there are some names of
informants
uh you know that's the kind of material
that was previously withheld but we're
talking about events that happened 50 or
60 years ago right it was 58 years ago
that that president kennedy was
assassinated so
the national security value of the
information that was held in most cases
it's minimal
or non-existent
uh let me invite to take a second to
invite our callers into the conversation
if you want to ask our guests questions
about this topic here's how you can call
us 202-748-8000
for those of you in the eastern and
central time zones and it's 202-748-8001
for those of you in the mountain of
pacific time zones you can text us at
202-748-8003
post comments on facebook and twitter as
well you go back to that deadline
october 26 2017 it goes to the trump
administration it gets extended why
trump said that this material had to be
withheld for anot another four years he
gave the cia the fbi and other federal
agencies another four years of secrecy
so that kicked the question to president
biden in october 2021
and again the cia and the fbi failed to
meet the deadline president biden
announced on october 22nd
that the agencies could continue to
withhold material and they had but they
had to deliver something by december
15th so last week
we got 10 percent of the 15 000
documents that still have redactions um
leaving 14 000 documents
which are supposed to be released a year
from now
but frankly i don't believe it i mean
they've blown the deadline twice and and
then on the third time around they give
us 10 percent of what the law requires
so clearly the cia doesn't want to obey
this law i mean they keep evading the
requirements of the law they've done it
three times now so i'm not sure that
we're ever going to see these records
but according to the law they're
supposed to be released a year from now
so that's kind of the big picture right
they've blown the deadline twice they've
doled out the minimal and these records
are most of these records have been seen
before not a lot of surprises in here
there's probably only out of those
1491 documents
most of which are from the cia about 900
are from the cia
we've seen these documents before for
the most part only a couple of them seem
to be entirely new
a couple of fbi documents but
the important thing is to step back and
look at kind of the big picture right
which is what have we learned since all
these documents began to come into the
record
since the 1990s what have we learned now
some people say well there's no smoking
gun and and try to end the conversation
there
you know that's kind of not really
looking at that's avoiding what these
records tell us what we've learned since
the 1990s is the official story that one
man came along and killed the president
and another guy came along and killed
batman and there was nothing to it there
was no politics involved that
explanation never particularly credible
has gotten less credible over time and a
couple of things that we've learned
since
since the mid 1990s from the new records
uh you know really stand out one
the story that this man lee harvey
oswald kind of came out of nowhere and
we didn't know anything about him that's
nonsense the cia knew all about lee
harvey oswald they had been following
him for four years they'd monitored all
of his actions
every piece of paper in the federal
government from the fbi the state
department the author of naval
intelligence the marine corps which
oswald was in all of that all of the
information about oswald went to one
place in the cia
the counter intelligence staff run by
james angleton and i talk about this in
in in my book the goes
so the idea that this guy came out of
nowhere and shot the president that's
the official story it's simply not true
i mean let's say oswald shot the
president i'm not sure he did but let's
say he did
the fact remains that we now know
top cia officials very senior undercover
operations officers were fully informed
about lee harvey oswald's movements his
personal life his political beliefs and
even his contacts with presumed foreign
intelligence agents were known to top
cia officers six weeks before kennedy
was killed
and then when kennedy was killed and
oswald was arrested for the crime the
cia pretended that they didn't know
anything about him and that
pretense we didn't really know anything
about this guy
we now know that that was a lie and it
was a lie from the start and that line
has continued to this day so really what
we learned from from
the release last week is they're still
holding back the whole story we have
calls lined up for you okay let's start
with ralph in new york uh for our guest
jefferson morley uh ralph good morning
thanks for calling go ahead
yes good good morning i got three
questions for your guest i'll be brief
sure uh what he thinks of him
the first one why did we never got a
satisfactory answer why did oswell wait
until kennedy got on elm street we had a
clear shot
on houston street uh for no other reason
for an ambush the second question is
jacqueline kennedy if you look at the
supruder film very closely
her head is right in front of the
president's head so it seems like if he
was shot from behind she would have been
assassinated and the third question is
if you watch it closely into the pruder
film
his left shoulder is bounced right off
the back seat cushion so he's really
floored and i thank you yeah uh the
caller makes a good question um you know
if oswald was in the sixth floor window
he had a much easier shot as the
motorcade approached as a as opposed to
when it was going away and what we see
is in the eyewitness testimony of the
people who were at the scene of the
crime you know a lot of people thought
that there was gunfire from two
different directions so the caller's
right it's a mystery if if that's the
explanation that oswald was acting alone
why why didn't he shoot earlier a very
good question jackie kennedy's position
during the assassination
she's the closest eyewitness to to what
happened right now
jackie kennedy never believed the
official story that one man alone killed
her president she did not believe that
she believed that the president was
killed by his domestic enemies and she
and bobby kennedy conveyed that message
we now know this is one of the things
we've learned since the 1990s
jackie kennedy and and bobby kennedy
told a friend who was going to the
soviet union in 1963 after the president
was killed and they they gave him a
message and they said we here's a
message for the leaders of the soviet
union
there's talk about oswald was a
communist we don't put any stock in that
we believe that the president was killed
by his domestic enemies and bobby
kennedy said i'm going to run for
president and if i regain the presidency
i'm going to continue my brother's
policies towards the soviet union so
jackie and bobby send a very friendly
message to the to this to the soviet
government saying we don't we don't buy
this business about oswald being a
communist or the president was killed by
a communist we believe he was killed by
domestic enemies that was a very strong
belief that they held bobby kennedy held
that belief for the rest of his life
in georgia this is michael good morning
morning gentlemen
i was five years old when all this
happened and it was my 9 11 up until my
my adulthood and
the haste with which he was assassinated
and buried three days i mean that was
telling me something but everything from
the national security memorandum 263 all
the way up to
um if you so my question is if you think
that the cia
was privy to what oswald was doing
do you think other uh upper echelon
people in the government might have
known also
thank you uh that's a very good question
thank you caller i was five years old
also when it happened so we're we come
we come to this with the exact same
experience i remember sitting around a
black and white tv i didn't know what
was going on but i knew something big
had happened and that was all um it's a
very good question you know what did
people
in the upper echelons of the cia know
about oswald as i said before you know
there was a group of of of top officials
the chief of operations in the western
hemisphere the chief of operations in
mexico city the assistant to counter
intelligence chief james angleton the
assistant to deputy director richard
helms all of these people were informed
about oswald's movements
uh you know six six weeks before the
assassination so what did they know
what did they make of oswald this is you
know this is part of why people still
want the rest of the story because we
really don't have a good explanation the
cia's never explained you know and i
hope that you know people will go to the
cia and ask them now that we have most
of the records not all of the records
but 95 percent of them does the cia have
an explanation for why so many top
officials knew about the man who was who
supposedly killed the president
and didn't do anything you know what's
the explanation for that we don't have a
good explanation that's why people are
still interested in these records
congress took this on during under the
warring commission what did you think of
those conclusions
the warren commission um was operating
you know at the mercy of the cia
basically and um and so i think that the
warren commission did not have access to
all the information i think they were
misled by the cia i mean i don't think i
know
on the day of the assassination after
oswald was arrested people went to the
cia and said
do you have anything on this guy who's
been arrested for killing the president
this former marine who had lived in the
soviet union and come back
and the cia said
we only we have a handful of documents
we have we have five records about him a
newspaper clipping from when he defected
and a few other things
that was the story on november 22nd 1963
the cia said we have five records about
them
that was a lie
the warren commission found out almost
by accident that the cia had other
records and they went back and asked the
cia for them so 10 weeks later
10 weeks the cia admitted no we didn't
have five documents on him we had 42
documents on him 42 documents collected
over the course of four years
this
the cia deputy director richard helms
told the warrant commission under oath
the information they had about oswald
was minimal
quote unquote minimal okay in fact they
knew his politics his personal life they
were reading his mail
that's how closely oswald was watched
they were reading his mail everywhere he
went the cia was updated
about his his uh you know where he was
living what he was doing so the cia was
very well informed and they basically
watched oswald come back from the soviet
union
come to texas
go to new orleans where he lived for a
little while he went to mexico city the
cia knew about that he came back from
mexico city he was living in texas the
cia was informed that lee harvey oswald
was in texas on november 15 1963.
that's how much they knew about him and
after the president was killed and
oswald was arrested and then killed
the cia played dumb and said we don't
know anything about this guy
that was a lie and so basically what we
found out last week is they're still
wild you know
one important thing did happen last week
and i i want to emphasize this you know
i get calls on you know uh 15
1491 jfk documents came out is there a
smoking gun in there
well you can't do historical research on
it you know on a newspaper deadline on
an internet deadline it just doesn't
work you've got to spend time with it
but one thing jumps out at me when in
going through the records and i haven't
gone through all of them yet but i'm i'm
getting there
one thing that is very important to
understand is i believe that now the
pre-assassination the cia's
pre-assassination file on lee harvey
oswald all the information that they
collected on him from 1959 to november
21st 1963
42 documents have now been declassified
in full for the first time
okay think about that it's been 58 years
and only last week did we have a
completely unredacted copy of all of
those records so what does that mean why
did it take 58 years to declassify the
cia's file on lee harvey oswald that's a
very good question and that's one that
jfk researchers are going to begin to
try and answer now we don't have an
explanation from the cia they're still
playing dumb
and they're still withholding records so
we face this problem of a recalcitrant
cia that doesn't want to obey the law
and has not com provided all the records
but we are beginning to get to the
complete historical record of kennedy's
assassination and that's an important
step a second thing
to call just real quick so moses in lake
elmo minnesota go ahead
yes good morning c-span good morning
america i really appreciate your
journalistic work here um
have you seen the oliver stone jfk
revisited great program
uh i was i was interviewed in it
yes i have seen it it's very good okay
it is very good and i must say that uh
my take on this whole thing
is when people start talking about no
one's above the law
you better believe there is and
eisenhower warned us of it and jfk got
right in the crosshairs of it when he
didn't give him air support down in cuba
on that stupid cia operation
they were not happy he was going to cut
the ca's budget by 20 to 30 percent he
wanted to shatter it into a thousand
pieces because they were too powerful
they were acting outside the law
and they're still still doing that today
arlen specter was the stu it was the the
one working on that commission for him i
can't believe they put dulles on there i
mean can you believe it the guy who gets
fired
ends up being on the commission that guy
was one of the weirdest dudes i've ever
seen and if you watch that that movie
you'll see how just creepy here yeah but
the bottom line is the cia took out our
president and nobody's been accountable
for it and that shot came from the front
the people went running after that shot
that came from the front
yeah because they want to chase down
this guy we'll let our guest answer
we'll let our guests answer that caller
thank you yeah
uh you know
a month after kennedy's assassination
former president harry truman the 33rd
president wrote an editorial in the
washington post
in which he called for the abolition of
the cia
now truman did not talk about jfk's
assassination in that column
and he never publicly linked his opinion
to kennedy's assassination but there's
no doubt that truman's call for the
abolition of the cia was a direct
response to the assassination of kennedy
harry truman knew more about the cia
than anybody he was the one who signed
it into existence in 1947.
let me say reluctantly initially harry
truman was against the creation of a
central intelligence agency a peacetime
intelligence agency
he said in 1945 we don't want an
american gestapo because a peacetime and
secret intelligence agency he viewed as
a threat to the democratic process two
years later
the cold war is heating up
truman wants a source of information and
he's he agrees he relents and allows the
the the creation of the cia and he signs
it into existence
when he's signing the cia into his
existence he's saying we have to make
sure that we don't have an american
gestapo he still had that same concern
about a secret police
fourteen years later kennedy was killed
truman had enough and he said let's
abolish the cia so the concern about the
cia and the kennedy's assassination
started immediately and it started at
the top of the u.s government it started
with harry truman
so that you know and then 58 years later
we see an agency that is refusing to
comply with the law
a law passed unanimously by congress
they still they've blown two deadlines
now they've blown three deadlines um you
know
people are
they they simply don't believe the cia
on this question this is why the cia has
to make these documents public they have
no credibility on jfk's assassination uh
just so we were talking earlier about
the statement from this white house
concerning the release they put out a
statement on october of this year the
22nd saying temporary continued
postponement is necessary to protect
against identifiable harm to the
military defense intelligence operations
law enforcement or the conduct of
foreign relations that is such gravity
that outweighs the public interest in
immediate discourse similar to what you
heard from the last administration on
this
yes and when you go and look at these
documents and you look at what's
redacted
you know identifiable harm to the
national defense
nothing nothing that was released last
week would have harmed the national
defense if it had been released four
years ago i guarantee you that nothing
was that was that rose to that level of
seriousness there may still be things
that are being withheld i believe that
there may be some true national security
information in these records but it's a
very tiny percentage it's not 14 000
documents which continue to have
redactions our guest jefferson worley
who was talking about the new jfk
assassination documents released this is
mike in west springfield massachusetts
good morning
good morning
this very important subject for me i was
alive during the day of kennedy
i have a question and my question is
when batista ran cuba before fidel
castro came into power the gambling
industry was on the roll of a lifetime
yes kennedy's failure to rid cuba of
fidel castro after he came to power cost
the gambling industry
a fortune because they were literally
run out of cuba yeah my question is
going past the cia
i think i was wondering
is there the possibility that those in
charge of the gambling industry
knowing they were all too pleased when
kennedy disappeared from the scene did
they have
a role
in
putting kennedy away
i'd like to know if you could comment on
that it's a tough question yeah and um
okay uh thank you colin we'll let him
answer uh
the caller's exactly right the gambling
industry was very big in havana in in
the late 1950s they were building hotels
they had extremely favorable uh income
tax provisions um
they had a free hand basically and they
were making lots of money and when
castro took power and you know had a
left-wing government they were driven
out and they lost lots of money and they
were very bitter about that and they
wanted to regain uh you know their
standing
i think that in recent years i haven't
seen evidence that that suggests that
organized crime were the intellectual
authors
of the assassination i do think that the
fact that jack ruby killed lee harvey
oswald and was jack ruby was a man who
aspired to be an organized crime figure
had friends in organized crime i think
that the assassination of oswald is a
sign of organized crime involvement in
the events of 1963. i don't think that
organized crime organized the
assassination of the president
let's hear from mary lou in connecticut
good morning you're next
good morning
yes that is true what you just said
fidel castro was behind the killing of
bobby and jack kennedy because
jack and bobby kennedy were going to
kill fidel castro
and he said oh no they're not going to
kill me i'm going to kill them
and
they were connected to
the chicago mafia through their father
in the prohibition era
and
so when they said that
um
that jack ruby was
from
fidel castro he got
fidel castro arranged stairhand and
fairhand and uh
with the oswald because neither one of
them are smart enough to ever pull off
something like that this was behind
fidel castro is
absolutely responsible for the killings
if i could say something there is
absolutely no evidence of that
there is no evidence that fidel castro
was involved in the in kennedy's
assassination
it's simply not true and
let's let's keep let's keep our eye on
on the news and what's going on now
fidel castro is not withholding 14 000
documents from the u.s public right he
has no he's dead
fidel castro didn't have anything to do
with kennedy's assassination fidel
castro said
after this on the day after the
assassination this is very bad news
kennedy was a man who was beginning to
make moves towards peace with cuba
castro was very disappointed and upset
about kennedy's killing because it made
life much more difficult for him
he had seen hope for reconciliation with
the united states under under kennedy
perhaps in his second term and this is
why kennedy's enemies hated him because
he did not invade cuba
not during the bay of pigs not during
the cuban missile crisis and so
the idea that fidel cash was behind the
assassination that was a notion that cia
assets put out right away
after the assassination but there's no
factual basis to it
why do you think after all these years
the the assassination still holds
fascination with people especially as
you hear people tell you various things
about what they think happened because
the government's never provided a
credible explanation because the cia's
been lying about it for 58 years
you know like i said before you know on
day one they told the first lie about
the assassination and those lies have
continued ever since you know and so
when people get a lot of lies and
they're asked to believe a story that's
not credible
um you know then they come up with you
know people are searching for an answer
and the reason the kennedy assassination
story endures is because we don't have a
good explanation of what happened and we
have a secret intelligence agency that
continues to withhold documents
of the murder of a president 58 years
later in defiance of a law i mean what
else are people gonna think but they
must be hiding something serious
you know why otherwise why wouldn't they
come clean i mean think about it if it's
so cut and dried this guy up and shot
the president you know case closed it's
very simple
if it was very simple
why did it take 58 years to declassify
the oswald file
you know that's the thing that the cia
can't explain and so the cia has this
big jfk problem it's like
you know they don't have a credible
story to tell and they have a lot to
hide that's the reality that we're
facing right now who's responsible at
the national archives to watch over this
material so the national archives um you
know they work with the agencies the
agencies are supposed to pass on any jfk
records that they have in their
uh you know in their possession the
archives you know puts them out to the
public but you know the archives is uh
it's a big government agency a budget of
about 350 400 million dollars a year but
you know they're dealing with the cia a
15 billion a year agency and so in that
situation the archives is not in a
position to
dictate anything to the cia it's the to
the contrary the cia dictates to the
national archives and so
you know if they don't want to release
something even though the law calls for
it you know the archives isn't really in
a position they don't have the force to
win you know enforce the law in the
1990s when we had the jfk review board
you know you had this independent agency
that could go to the to
the cia or the fbi and say you know we
want this document we're going to make
it public you know and the agency had to
comply there's no independent authority
now which is why the cia feels that you
know they have this sense of impunity
congress passed a law and said produce
all the jfk records you know at the
c.i.a they say you know we don't feel
like obeying that law so you know we're
not going to obey it and trump went
along with them
and biden went along with them you know
that's the power that they have congress
passes a law they don't want to buy obey
it they don't obey it
this is from edison new jersey steve is
next
good morning gentlemen
[Music]
i believe
what this man is saying mr morley is
absolutely right i wonder
if he's come across the james file
confession
and david adley phillips yeah he noticed
those two names yeah
uh the caller referenced james files is
a a man who was in prison i think he got
out recently in the last couple of years
um who claimed that he was the assassin
that he that he was the one who shot the
president um you know
files doesn't have any independent
corroboration of his story and so it's a
little hard to know what to make of it
um he could have
based on what he said
i think he could have learned all of the
things that he said from just reading
the literature of the assassination so i
don't know i i don't disbelieve it i
don't believe it i just think we don't
know enough to to whether we should
credit that story you referenced david
atlee phillips
david atlee phillips was mentioned by
james files he was a senior operations
officer in the cia
he's one of the senior officers who i
mentioned before who knew about all
about oswald before the assassination
there's a big file on david atley
phillips that is that remains with many
many redactions and we did not see any
of that last week so he's a person of
interest david phillips is a person of
interest to jfk researchers
he knew a lot about oswald before the
assassination when he was called before
investigations he told a whole bunch of
stories about oswald
some of them quite contradictories he
couldn't keep his oswald stories
straight
so another reason why people are
skeptical about the cia's role in that i
mean if it's so simple that oswald up
and shot the president
why why why would you tell so many
different stories about him you know
that's a good question about david
phillips there's a lot of information
that has not been made public about him
uh mr uh
mr morley have you or any other
journalist that you know have tried to
get information about the assassination
through freedom of information act uh
yes we have um
i spent 16 years in court with the cia
pursuing jfk records and obtained a
bunch of material i was looking for
information about cia propaganda
operations involving oswald this is one
another one of the revelations that
we've had since the 1990s
it turns out that the people who
immediately sought to blame kennedy's
assassination on cuba on fidel castro
were paid cia agents working under a
program called amspel that was the code
name amspel
and we only learned in the last
15 or 20 years just how much amspell was
controlled by the cia and and run by the
cia so
the president is killed and cia assets
are immediately putting out the story oh
cuba's to blame cuba's to blame
well why did they do that who was behind
that my lawsuit under the freedom of
information act was designed to get at
that question who were the officers who
knew about this operation and we learned
we learned a fair amount about that but
the cia stonewalled and they were backed
up by the courts and so a lot of the
story we never got why were cia assets
generating propaganda about oswald both
before and after the assassination
there's an 87-page document on the
amspel program that is heavily redacted
it was not released last week so
we have important information about cia
operations around the accused assassin
that are still secret this is the
problem we face
jim in pittsburgh pennsylvania hi
yeah jim pittsburgh i just want to know
if anybody has asked
robert f kennedy jr
about the uh
this the cia who's he who incidentally
spoke
in
milan italy on november 16th
yeah um robert kennedy jr the son of rfk
has
said that he believes uh his uncle
president kennedy was killed by a
conspiracy from within his own
government so i don't know that he has
talked about the cia specifically but he
whole he believes that his uncle was
killed by enemies within the u.s
government and he's he's said that you
know repeatedly over the years
uh that was jim we'll hear next from
david david is uh
apologies for the uh david from missouri
david good morning hi good morning pedro
and mr morley i would like to ask your
opinion on a book and i'm sure you have
read and i'm not going to plug the book
but tom hartman from free speech tv and
a cohort of his while he hartman was a
journalist did a book on this and it
goes coincides with the organized crime
in the cia being at fault thank you very
much
uh yeah i i have read tom hartman's book
um i don't agree with all of it but i
think that the picture that he paints
the
the the the the situation in 1963 that
kennedy was in the forces arrayed
against him i think his book is very
good on that you know on that particular
on the setting of the assassination and
and and what happened who's ken who who
kennedy's enemies were at that time
uh mr morley we have a viewer who asked
you've referenced him but wanted to know
more about what you know about jack ruby
or at least what you think is important
to know about jack ruby at this state
you know
so jack ruby is the man who killed lee
oswald the supposed assassin of the
president um
why did he kill
why did he kill oswald
ruby was asked this afterwards and his
lawyer told him say that you did it to
spare jackie kennedy the pain of a trial
and so that's what ruby mouthed those
words and that became like oh yes he was
trying to spare jackie kennedy you know
that is a totally preposterous claim
jack ruby ran a strip club he was a pimp
he beat up people regularly in his club
his best friend was a dog he had no
feelings whatsoever for jackie kennedy
and he despised bobby kennedy because
bobby kennedy's relentless efforts to
prosecute organized crime figures
you know i i interviewed a woman who
knew ruby well um she contacted me
through my website jfk [ __ ] and she had
been a dancer in jack ruby's club and
they became friends ruby was very sweet
on her and you know asked her to marry
her and she was like that you're that's
ridiculous jack i'm not gonna marry you
and so i asked her so why did your
friend jack you know why did he kill
oswald and she said i asked him that and
he didn't really answer but she said
i'll tell you one thing
i don't think he had any choice and he
said what do you mean she said you know
everybody works for somebody and jack
worked for people
and i think he had to kill oswald i
don't think he had any choice i said who
was it she said i don't know you know
she was 20 years old at the time but she
was convinced that ruby did not have any
choice about killing oswald that he had
to do it so
ruby was uh in jail
in dallas and chief justice warren came
to visit him
and ruby said if you take me back to
washington i'll tell you the whole story
this is to chief justice earl warren
earl warren didn't do that because earl
warren didn't want to know and so ruby
never they never brought ruby back to
uh to washington to testify to explain
what he said was the whole story and so
ruby stayed in jail and he died of
cancer uh three years after the
four years after the assassination all
right this is patty in connecticut hi
good morning
hi
i'm relating to that
ruby uh told uh was visited by
dorothy kilgallen yes
and she um
she got all the information from him and
she of course was bragging she's going
to release it all of course she died she
died untimely death
and
they said she was on drugs
right um
and then uh
allegedly the rumors were that lyndon
johnson was behind it
because he was being bought before
congress on a corruption the same day of
the assassination
can you talk about that please
yeah i mean it it's true that uh lyndon
johnson uh was under investigation his
his sidekick a man named bobby baker was
had been
implicated in various corruption schemes
and johnson was
under investigation for that and it's
not clear whether kennedy was going to
keep johnson on the ticket in 1964 or
not there was some speculation that he
might replace him i don't think kennedy
had made up his mind about that i don't
see any evidence that johnson was
involved in the assassination
but i think he knew instantly what had
happened and that's why after oswald was
killed
johnson and fbi director j edgar hoover
got together on november 25th two days
after the assassination three days after
the assassination and they agreed
they were they would investigate and
that they would find that oswald alone
had killed the president and johnson and
hoover were very specific we need to cut
off speculation about oswald's motives
we need to cut off speculation about his
associations
very quickly people at the top of the
government realize the most convenient
truth
was this one guy did it and nobody else
is responsible and we're not going to
investigate anybody in the u.s
government involved in this and so they
decided what they wanted to find before
the investigation had even begun before
kennedy had been buried
johnson and hoover decided they had the
solution one guy did it alone for no
reason the warren commission ratified
that
that that finding um but it was never
particularly credible
it simply wasn't you know people say oh
you know conspiracy theorists it was
very simple and this is a thing that's
been ginned up by conspiracy theorists
no that's simply not true factually
pollsters went out a week after the
assassination and they you know did
a statistically valid poll thousand
people what do you think happened in
dallas who was responsible and all that
in the two polls that were done that
week
60 to 70 percent of the people in dallas
and nationwide said more than one person
was involved at that time there were no
conspiracy theorists oliver stone was in
boarding school in pennsylvania
and so it wasn't conspiracy theorists
who came up with
more than one person was involved it was
the circumstances of the crime that
created that belief it was not
conspiracy theorists it was the simple
facts of the matter
and
the government's explanation
this guy did it alone you know
people never really believed it um they
didn't believe it right after the
assassination and over time that
explanation has gotten less credible
and with all the information that we got
in the 1990s it has become even less
credible so the official theory
is you know has failed it doesn't
explain what happened on november 22nd
1963.
so we still don't know uh one more call
this will be from
zanesville ohio
good morning c-span
you're on go ahead sir
okay uh
the question i have for mr morley is
does he put any credence in the theory
that somehow the secret service
accidentally
from the
limo behind the president's car
accidentally shot him when yeah the car
accelerated yeah
it's nonsense it's a hoax there's no
evidence to support it
photographic eyewitness forensic
evidence it's just one of those things
that people make up um it's really
unfortunate that
that that story is still around the guy
who offered that theory you know
retracted it under threat of of legal
uh you know legal action so no it's
nonsense uh to finish up if you had full
access to the documents available to you
where would you start
i would start with um
those propaganda operations around
oswald before and after the
assassination that is the most
suspicious thing that we have why was
the cia putting trying to blame the
crime on
on on cuba right after kennedy was
killed we still don't have a good
explanation of of who was behind that
and uh you know what they were trying to
achieve by that that's where i would
start jefferson morley is the author of
several books including the cia and jfk
the secret assassination files his
website is jfkfax.org
mr morley thanks for your time happy
holidays to you thank you
coming up we're going to talk about how
other countries are responded to covid
particularly in light of omicron our
guest is medics global president and ceo
seigel atzman and we'll talk to her
about what she's seeing worldwide when
washington journal continues
[Music]
c-span is your unfiltered view of
government we're funded by these
television companies and more including
charter communications